hey for someone who's so you know you're
obviously so talented you've done so
much work you've been on
series i mean parenthood lasted for six
years five years
yeah six yeah i mean you've done movies
and this
has this bit been a tough time for
someone who
you know loves working and it's just a
weird time anyway it's like i don't even
want to work during this time i can't
imagine being on set with masks and this
and protocols and tests and i just
rather like let it go let it get done
and let's get back to work
but i don't know how how it's going to
be what are you are you doing anything
right now have you decided like hey i'm
going to wait until
kind of [ __ ] gets better or are you like
craving to work
i'm cr i'm yes the ladder i'm craving to
work
i well having all this time with the
kids has been
amazing and at their ages where
they need you know direct supervision
and contact so much of the time
anyway and we've done all these family
adventures
even i mean and we've also been
responsible we've also you know
not left the house for large periods of
time um
but it's been really fun and i know that
i would be
taking it even harder if i didn't have
the kids
but i i want to get back to work
you know that betsy brant lives kind of
near us she was walking by the house
yesterday
and she was like let me tell you when
you go back to work
the anxiety will hit you it's going to
be weird you're going to get tested
everybody's wearing you know and then
there's like
wanting to keep your space from people
and then they only do
i think one person in the hair and
makeup trailer at a time which is very
slow but i
but yeah i want to go back to work i
trust i trust hollywood to do it
responsibly
i just found out from my friend that's
working on um
what's what's ted danse's new show
kramer versus kramer
what is it mr mayor mr mayor
what you wanna audition for that no no
my my buddy
is uh is pulling focus on that and he
said
they had to shut down early but he said
the studio is spending
a fortune on testing and prevention
measures like it's a safe
it's a safe thing you know if anybody
tests positive anywhere
you